since there are plain highlights of it
all week how do you kind of look back at
the diggs miracle catch game you get a
warm fuzzy feeling every time you see
the replays of it or what would you say
we're concentrating on the saints this
week we don't care about three years ago
or whatever it was it's like every
few months the nfl page personally like
bro it's over with yeah they didn't win
the super bowl and we didn't win the
super bowl it was just a play there that
was a great play it happened one in a
million play but all right it's over
that's mike zimmer the vikings coach
marshawn lattimore who was on the field
for the minneapolis miracle was a poorly
designed defense i remember we broke
that apart and it just was a bad bad
play by the saints and it worked out
perfectly for the vikings but it's over
it's done it has no bearing on this game
but there is such a clear and obvious
connection between the teams they it was
just two years ago two cycles ago of
course it's going to get mentioned and
and i i think that the the worst thing
the saints could do
is dwell on that or dwell on what
happened last year they've got to forget
about two years of playoff failure and
focus on the task at hand and i think
the bigger challenge for them
psychologically chris is getting over
the idea that they shouldn't be playing
at all this weekend sure right right
they should have a buy the seahawks
should have won and there were multiple
opportunities for the seahawks to win
including
one that came from a non-call of
defensive pass interference so i i think
that's really the challenge for sean
payton getting his guys to embrace this
moment when they know deep down they
should be sitting back watching four
other teams play well i i've gotten to
the point where i'm done questioning
that like you know i mean i think you
you should too i mean we one thing we
know is i mean sean payton's just a hell
of a coach and his team's always ready
and they're always tough and they're
just they're they're always prepared you
know they we you know you didn't pick
them to go to the playoffs this year why
because you didn't think they were gonna
i'm just like throwing you under the bus
on that one but why i get it because we
just weren't sure they could bounce back
i think they've answered every question
the whole year oh drew brees
i wasn't sure about drew brees yeah i
wasn't sure about breeze even before he
got hurt i thought father time was
starting to catch up to him and he ends
up having statistically the best season
of his career right and i get you and
then you know he does get hurt and we go
oh what will happen with the saints oh
they go 5-0 without drew brees so they
constantly answer the bell and i have no
doubt about that i really don't i i
really like listen mike i just i look at
this game and just go how did the
vikings have a chance
just ask that's what i really want to
say can the vikings keep this close i
think the saints are going to whoop
whoop the crap out of your minnesota
vikings i'm sorry but i don't disagree i
think it's going to happen
thomas
listen yesterday mike zimmer was asked
about xavier rhodes potentially covering
michael thomas are you can he seem to
suggest that that's how he's gonna do it
are you kidding me xavier rhodes on
michael thomas he'll have 20 catches
well yeah yes it's not going to be great
that way and you know minnesota okay
xavier rhodes is a big guy i think
that's probably where that logic is he's
big he can you know maybe handle the
physicality of michael thomas you're a
big guy too well you're right and i
couldn't cover him worth a damn you're
exactly right and out of the fact that
it's a whole different ball game when
michael you know michael thomas is all
of a sudden in the slot 90 of the game
and you can go two different ways out of
that slot position as far as inside or
outside it's not like you know oh i'm on
the outside and have a sidelines over
here so if xavier roach is going to
match up against michael thomas in the
slot good night xavier rose and the
minnesota defense but that's what scares
me minnesota's defense okay yes it's a
good front four but it's a great
offensive line in the saints the run
game has picked up you know i think the
minnesota defense a little too
predictable at times and how they line
up and things i don't think that bodes
well against sean payton and drew brees
so that's scary in itself i i just look
at the saints and just think it's only a
matter of time before they start moving
the ball on that minnesota defense
and then the other side oh what do you
guys want to do run the ball with dalvik
great you know i just the saints d line
is they're they're one of the best in
football at stopping the run and then
i'm not going to sit here and go well i
expect kirk cousins and this
underwhelming passing attack uh when
they don't have the bootlegger play
action available because the run game's
not working i expect them to take over
no i don't i i think minnesota's in deep
trouble in this football game this is
one where i'm not even hiding my pick i
think the saints are going to win this
game in dominant fashion and be pissed
off that they're playing it all
is there any
set of facts that you envision where
you could be wrong where the vikings
could steal this i mean this is the
first time they've got all their weapons
healthy on offense since week six right
thielen is back out of the feeling great
receiver he didn't have any catches week
16 against the packers but he claims
he's healthy stefan diggs is healthy
dalvin cook is healthy alexander madison
is healthy both guys fully participated
in practice on wednesday
i if if they can if they can run the
ball formula if they can run the ball
then it opens up the bootlegs it opens
up the play action passes you're not
gonna win with conventional drop back
pocket passing from kirk cousins because
he doesn't have enough time and he
doesn't have that tom brady style of
anticipation the walls close in on him
and it doesn't work if you don't have
that defensive line lose a little bit
steam worrying about dalvin cook and
alexander madison and i think it all
comes down to whether or not they can
run the ball and if they and we'll know
early yeah we will i think it's safe to
say the vikings either going to be in
this or they're going to get blown off
the field and and then there is that
that very real sean payton dynamic where
we've seen him dissect the mike zimmer
defenses in the past he knows where the
holes are he knows what the tendencies
are because it is a system it is not a
game specific right attack yes yes
exactly right that's it it is a system
and there's a certain way they approach
things you know if mike zimmer doesn't
throw a few curveballs at sean peyton
it's gonna be a long day he's gonna have
to do that but you know to your point
too with the run game you're right
that's going to be to me where it's won
and lost yeah minnesota's been a very
good running football team this year
especially when dalvin cook is healthy
he's arguably the best tailback in
football when he's been healthy but man
the the new orleans saiyans they got
some dudes up front i mean some big
heavy hitters who could stop the run
when you just start talking about you
know the size of some of the guys they
got they got so many 300 and 320
pounders 310 pound i mean cam jordan
he's a defensive end and he's 290 pounds
that just tells you to the size of their
football team and i just have a hard
time thinking that minnesota can
dominate that group in the run game and
then open up all the things that you
mentioned
yeah i i agree with you i think it would
be even more stunning not even more
stunning it would be as stunning as that
game back in 1987 when the vikings and
the saints got together and the vikings
somehow stunned the saints i don't see
it happening
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports